hi in this video I'm going to talk about
circular dichroism and circular
dichroism spectroscopy circular
dichroism spectroscopy is a very good
technique to determine the structural
information about a protein especially
the secondary structure of a protein and
also it gives us information about
protein folding and lots of other
information that we would see at the end
of the video now like any other
spectroscopic circular dichroism is
quite similar so let's see what happens
in our visible spectroscopy so we have
our sample here in a container and what
we would do we would shine light inside
the container and some amount of light
is absorbed by the solution and some
amount of light would be transmitted and
the transmitted light would hit a
detector and the drawn some amount of
transmitted light would hit a detector
and we would detect the absorbance of
that particular solution and using that
absorbance we would understand the
concentration as we know from a
beer-lambert law so the absorbance would
be equal to extinction coefficient into
path length into concentration so this
is our basic spectroscopy equation from
beer-lambert law so our circular
dichroism spectroscopy is quite similar
instead of any kind of light we use here
polarized light and so here we have a
light source here we have a light source
and here we have a polarizer a polarizer
is a substance which would polarize the
light so when light passes through this
light would be polarized and I am
representing polarized light in this
form and or when it would
cross another p.m. it would be converted
into two type of light so one light
would be circled each type of light
would be circularly polarized light so
we can think about any plane parallel
polarized light as a combination of two
circularly polarized light I mean the
superposition of a left circularly
polarized light and a right circularly
polarized light
so here we are representing a right
circularly polarized light and here we
are representing a left circularly
polarized light so we are writing LCP
for left circularly polarized light and
we are writing RCP for right circularly
polarized light so if we just see in our
case the plane polarized light the
electric field vector actually vibrates
along one direction in the plane so if
it is the direction of the wave
propagation and the electric field
vector would oscillate in only this
direction but in case of circularly
polarized light the scenario would be
different electric field vector would
actually vibrate in both the plane so if
we have our electric field vector so it
would be a combination of right
circularly polarized light and a left
circularly polarized light and when this
combination of light right circular
polarized light and left circularly
polarized light enter our sample
provided that our sample is optically
active
that means the sample is keidel some
changes in the absorbance would happen
and some light would be absorbent and
this term is differential observation so
differential absorption means it would
like it would absorb the right polarized
light in a different extent than the
left polarized light so for instance
here our right polarized light after
absorption the transmitted light a right
polarized light looks like something
this and the left polarize polarized
light is reduced in the amplitude so as
this amplitude varies now after the
transmission we won't get our linear
polarized light when these two
superimposes rather than a linear
polarized light we would now get
something called elliptically polarized
elliptical polarized light and this
degree of ellipticity is actually the
measure of Cyclone circular dichroism so
we can think about circular dichroism in
terms of absorbing absorb a ssin
absorption difference so we can think
about circular dichroism in terms of
absorption difference so we have
absorption for left polarized light say
a l and we have absorption for right
polarized light as a R so this would be
the measure of circular dichroism and
this absorption for a left polarized
light and right polarized light would be
actually e l-
ER where these are the extinction
coefficient for left and right polarized
light respectively times the path length
and the concentration of the particular
kindly active substance so we can say
that Delta absorbance is equal to Delta
Epsilon times L that means the path
length and the concentration and the
degree of ellipticity
the degree of ellipticity is actually is
the measure of circular dichroism also
this 2.303 difference in absorption of
right and left-circularly polarized
light into 180 by 4pi so this is the
method measure of the circular dichroism
and if we just want to talk about what
is a left circular polarized light and
the what is right circular polarized
light so the helix sense is different in
both the cases so here we have what we
called a right circularly polarized
light so right circularly polarized
light will actually look somewhat like
this this would be the hellicksen's and
if we see from our cross sectional view
we would see a circle and the electrical
field vector is actually rotating our
clockwise on the other side if we talk
about a left circular polarized light
and the hellicksen's is also different
in this case and we would get a cross
sectional view like this but the
electric field vector is rotating in a
counterclockwise fashion so this is the
basic difference between our left
circularly polarized light and a right
circularly polarized light so I'm
denoting it as left circularly polarized
light LCP and this as RCP that means
right circularly polarized light okay
so let's see what are the use of this
extra scoping so CD are used for CD is
actually used for
protein secondary structural
determination so for instance if you
want to determine how much alpha helix
or beta pleated sheet is present in our
protein so see these are good technique
and pH induced or heat induced or
solvent induced structural changes could
be also detected by our circular
dichroism spectroscopy otherwise protein
folding and unfolding information could
be also predicted by the circular
dichroism ligand or ion induced
structural changes in the protein
secondary structure could be also
detected by CD
moreover structural aspect of nucleic
acid polysaccharides polypeptides and
hormones could also be derived from the
CD spectra so let's see how the CD
spectra for our some secondary structure
looks like normally so here we have our
y-axis in our y-axis we have our molar
ellipticity so it is drawn as theta and
in the x axis we would have lambda that
means the wavelength of our light so
let's say our wavelength we have 200 220
to 240 and so and this is the value of
the ellipticity here it is - and here it
would be positive and now the spectra
for the Alpha helix would somewhat look
like this and the spectra for beta
pleated sheet would somewhat look like
this and ultimately the random coil or
turns would look like this
so this is turns this is bit a sheet and
this is alpha helix
this is our families so if there any
change occurred after ligand-binding
or due to any other conditions the basic
spectre of alpha helix beta pleated
sheet or the turns would be changed with
respect to a control if we compare these
two spectra then we could get
information how and how and why the
changes in the secondary structure of
the protein occurred and this is how our
CD spectroscopy is very useful to
determine any changes in two-degree
structure or to gain knowledge about
protein folding and protein unfolding so
that's all about circular dichroism hope
you enjoyed the video please like and
don't forget to subscribe please leave
your comments thank you